we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p i this is so funny i
mentioned at the end of last week that
we now have multiple tiers of youtube
membership we're part of a beta testing
a feature on YouTube where people can
become YouTube members originally there
was one pricing tier which is $4.99 we
now have more pricing tiers starting at
$1.99 including one called soy boy you
can be a beta and alpha you can even
become David Pakman for $99.99 a month
and a self a self-confessed drunk caller
does not like the membership pricing
scheme take a listen to this David
Pakman and be here from Tippecanoe
County really have a problem with your
and you're not the only one witness is
99 here joined for $1.99 $49.99 a
hundred dollars and 99 cents why don't
we just say two dollars instead of a
dollar ninety-nine you know the gas
station people they all do this I hate
it you know two thirty nine point nine
it's 240 a gallon
come on how do I want to say it's a
misnomer it's just a sorry I've had a
couple drinks but anyway get over the 99
if it's a dollar ninety-nine to join
just say two dollars please
this actually is not our choice so
interestingly enough there's a lot of
pricing psychology that asserts that
pricing something at $1.99 even though
it's only a penny off from two dollars
people see that it starts with a 1 and
at the deepest level of your
consciousness it just seems
significantly cheaper than something
that is $2.00 so there's like the
pricing psychology side of it we did not
choose that all of the prices on the
YouTube tiers YouTube membership tiers
end in 99 that's how YouTube set it up
and we literally could pick anywhere
from I think it was from 99 cents up to
4 $99.99 and that's that's how it works
so it would not be my choice necessarily
on
website memberships are six bucks a
month 12 bucks a month 24 48 or 60 for
the year or whatever I get it this was
not our choice but $1.99 to become a soy
boy I think is pretty good so check that
out on our YouTube channel but if you're
currently a member on our website if
you're currently a patron everything's
fine you don't need to switch to youtube
membership it's just an additional
option that is out there and exists
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about Ruth Bader
Ginsberg of the Supreme Court discharged
from the hospital recuperating at home
after surgery Utah has lowered its the
UI limit to 0.05 from the common 0.08 is
a common number in a lot of the country
we will also talk about the stock
market's erratic behavior after a 12
point 2 percent year-to-date decline a
thousand point gain yesterday and then
immediately down 400 points intraday
right now an extraordinarily erratic
stock market what does it all mean
what can we predict nothing and much
more on today's bonus show get the bonus
show by becoming a member becoming a
patron look forward to speaking to you
then